- So...
you two need a little help.
- The overall premise of "False Positive"
is about this white,
well-to-do New York City couple
who has been trying
for a long time to get pregnant.
And they embark on this pregnancy journey.
- Oh.
- You are 100% pregnant.
[laughter]
- We are specifically exploring
the horrors
that come up in this world.
It really is a scary experience
from the inside out.
- This film is not necessarily
a genre film.
It's a psychological satire.
- Brilliant.
- I wanted to create a woman
who assumed that her life
was more empowered
than it really was.
- Am I gonna be one of those women
who has it all?
My career, my kids, my old man by my side?
- Who you calling old?
- Lucy, to me, is an Instagram liberal,
you know, like,
someone who has a lot of privilege
and slowly wakes up to a reality
that she's been kind of pushed into
that she didn't need to participate in.
- I'm having the wildest
mommy brain lately.
- [gasps]
I am not crazy. They're trying to make me
think that I'm crazy.
- The frame we're widening out to
in reviewing the power structures
that run this world are a lot.
- There's a lot of voodoo out there.
We just want to make sure
that you get the best possible care.
- [spits]
- If you just think about what a woman
goes through when she becomes pregnant,
she has to make a choice--
"Do I want to have children or not?
"Do I give up work or not?
Am I a mom or an employee?"
They all fit under this larger umbrella
of misogyny.
- The way that our society works makes
pregnant people "the most vulnerable."
- Hey...
this pregnancy shit is no joke, right?
- Push.
- [screams]
- Damn, pregnancy and horror
does go together very well.